let's talk about this controlled
opposition I got this tweet here from
chairwell that says Peter Thiel bashes
Greta and the autistic Children's
Crusade in his address at the Oxford
Union blaming environmentalism for some
of the greatest crises of our time
andyway reports that's a bold statement
from uh from Peter Thiel about Greta
it's interesting though because you know
what's what's Peter thiel's deal I mean
isn't he like a Davos group or no he's
not he's not I think that stuff probably
was former Davos I mean I think he's
kind of old-school Silicon Valley right
when Silicon Valley started these guys
were like Tech Libertarians like we're
given a voice to the people and then
money and Banks and all that got
involved
um you know I was going to say to your
point there's three things you can't
audit the Federal Reserve our elections
and the dod budgets so so we got Greta
tunberg which is I guess what blanket
controlled opposition fairly obvious to
anybody she hasn't protest in China she
protests the West which is doing
everything its power to get rid of
carbon emissions Peter Thiel comes out
and and bashes Greta calling it Greta
and the autistic Children's Crusade but
this guy I thought I thought Peter you
know I know Peter thiel's had some good
opinions but I thought he was like
Bilderberg he well I mean he just
sponsored JD Vance and Blake Masters for
sale which I think is a testament to him
I was out of Blake Masters fundraiser in
Miami at Peter thiel's house and he gave
a quick speech and I was admittedly like
I was like wait Peter Thiel is like a
Silicon Valley guy Facebook like come on
I'm not and his his speech which you
know early PayPal was great current
PayPal sucks early PayPal was amazing
yeah uh and his speech blew me away
three minutes and I was like ooh he's a
good guy now and I think we've seen that
with Elon Musk with you know Joe Rogan
like these guys they're kind of getting
more and more emboldened with Tim Poole
um I I think uh he said we have about
three years left to save America from a
communist takeover Peterson
I mean he has a very last year he has it
too he has a very interesting career
especially what happened with BuzzFeed
as especially him being ousted by them
and then kind of getting retribution
through Hogan him coming out and
supporting Donald Trump especially
during the RNC was pretty ballsy too but
he has a very interesting kind of career
he's also with palantir with Alex karp
who was at Davos uh today specifically
talking about how he is a progressive
helping the intelligence agencies uh and
and working on AI technology that will
help track down Russians in in the
battlefield but also given this
technology to the U.S intelligence
agencies and how a lot of progressives
should be happy that he's doing so
because he's stopping a lot of
right-wing terrorist attacks but that's
you know Alex carp another Bilderberg
member who's working with Peter Thiel uh
on palateer I talked to Peter Thiel
twice at Bilderberg already uh and he is
a Bilderberg steering committee member
so there's a lot of mystery there
there's still a lot of questions I would
love to have a bigger discussion with
him he's kind of a little mysterious
figure but but I think definitely there
deserves to be a bigger conversation to
be had with him
uh because he's he's interesting I I
agree too and you know look we're doing
the whole coffee shop thing the cafe
skate shop physical location stuff and
it's and it's particularly inexpensive
relative to uh um other businesses like
setting up a coffee shop is not as
expensive as setting up like a media
company I bring this up because I wonder
with Peter Thiel being worth what is he
like two billion dollars I'm genuinely
curious I'm not saying he's doing
nothing but I'm wondering if he really
feels this way about how we got three
years to save this country what is he
doing and again not saying he took
nothing I'm genuinely curious like what
are his approaches and and strategies
with all of his his resources to try and
save this country if he even is I I've
only seen what has been public I mean
you know it kind of Bilderberg he was on
the Facebook board right and you would
you'd think oh that's bad because
Facebook is very censoring and they kick
the president United States off but it's
also kind of good because we want some
representation on that board too so you
know there is a kind of a flip side to
it but all I can attest to I'm not a
Peter teal expert but he did back those
two Senate candidates he put I think he
was like the second or third biggest GOP
donor he recognizes that the time at
this in this country where we're at and
um I I imagine he'll be a big supporter
in 2024 but I don't know fully what his
plan is the palantir thing's interesting
it's basically spy Tech and it's like
new 21st century spy Tech from what I
know I know very little about it uh
except that it's spy Tech I just want to
make a correction really quick it wasn't
BuzzFeed it was Gawker I apologize no uh
with Peter Thiel and Hogan uh the Hogan
Law oh yeah right right right so I
apologize I misspoke what was that
lawsuit to clarify really quick Docker
published uh sex tape of Hulk Hogan the
hawkster yeah and it was so brutal they
should not have done that and uh but
they were like oh it's what we do and
Peter Thiel then funded the lawsuit and
it's because Gawker outed him as gay
okay but the thing the thing is it's
crazy is like he does work around the
world he could be killed in some of
these places yeah like the Middle East
especially you know which is which is a
huge danger to him and it wasn't it
wasn't a newsworthy story it was a
gossip story that they tried to of
course hurt him over which was again
ridiculous but sorry
big thing that people need to discuss
because they have a big presence in the
intelligence community and the
intelligence Community the FBI the CIA
depends on them a lot yeah I invest I
was advised hey palantir invest so I did
I like made like 10 times my money on
the freaking thing in the beginning Ian
comes up to me one day I'm in this was
like a year and a half before covet it
was like right around when covet was
beginning no early 2012. you came we
were here oh yeah I'm in my front office
and then you walk up and you're like
dude my friends are saying you got to
buy a bunch of palantir stock and I was
like I'm not going anywhere near there
yeah yeah I know I was like when it
comes to investment it's not about what
you believe in it's about what you know
is going to make you money unfortunately
sickeningly I do that every once in a
while you can get really rich really
quick I sold it all but anyway I think
what's happening is I brought this up
last night in the after show that maybe
the CIA the FBI NSA are the good guys
and the we are inadvertently have been
cannibalizing yourself is there a mute
button because you know it's only good
relative to what else there is the other
options which are the CCP the world
economic performance so it's like the
liberal economic order versus brics and
then where in the world they are already
bought out by the CCP I think the CCP is
so embedded I mean we already oh social
credit scores we already have that go
ask someone like Laura Loomer Alex Jones
yeah but like the CCP is the testing
grounds for the elites to push a lot of
their unpopular policies to see the
compliance levels that they want to
bring to the West uh and this is like
you know Ian I think you have the
Twilight Saga view of werewolf and
vampires whereas like the the classical
view is if a werewolf and a vampire are
fighting each other over you it's
because they want to eat you not because
they want to date you and so like the
way you're describing like maybe they're
the good guys insofar as worse bad guys
I'm like yeah that's like you're
imagining sparkly vampires who are just
like I'm so love with you I promise
they're not the guys the lower level
people are generally good people working
hard and want to bust bad guys the guys
at the top are evil as corrupt as they
can yeah
Alex carp's uh the CEO of palantir had a
lot of interesting comments today at
Davos he was talking about how incutel
was one of the first kind of startups
for a lot of these larger bigger tech
companies he was talking about how the
CIA the FBI the dod were all involved
and now how a lot of these bigger tech
companies are more aligned to the West
uh because of that he was going off and
talking about how they are creating
algorithms that palantir that are
specifically used to quote Target
Russians on the battlefield and later he
went on and said the US government has
our software and uses it very
aggressively that's Alex carp today
um CEO of palantir at Davos today very
eye-opening comments to say the least
yes I don't I don't think anybody at the
NSA is a good person not a sing not a
single one I just don't know them all
and I know companies aren't monoliths
the NSA is is a fourth amendment meant
violating organizations there's no
question I don't think that anybody at
the NSA is like sitting there saying I
know we're in violation of the the rule
the law of the land of this country in
violation of our Oaths to uphold the
Constitution but oh well like there's
there's no circumstance or they don't
know because sometimes not doing it what
do you mean they don't know if you don't
if you weren't educated about the
Constitution you wouldn't know that's
called the banality of evil yeah so
these people and then when you when they
when they learn they're like oh oh oh
I'm not doing that anymore like people
will wake up you ever see that Family
Guy joke where it was a there's a murder
in prison and then he's holding a knife
and he like pokes himself and goes whoa
is that what I'm doing to people I
deserve to be in here like like as if
they don't know I don't know maybe maybe
but it's just like dude look the chicken
poster just fell oh no okay but it's an
omen the NSA is listening literally a
lot of poster it's a painting okay very
nice meeting I'll fix it it's a Fed guy
behind behind the wall with a glass with
a hearing glass listen they were they
were you know
you know I'm not going to use Nazi
Germany as an example let's let's use
Soviet Russia yeah there were a lot of
people working for the gulag who are
just like look I don't know what this
guy did they told me he's a bad guy and
his crime was that he he said we deserve
better there's a guy sitting in his
apartment and he's like looking at how
awful everything is Soviet Union and he
goes outside and he goes I think we
deserve better and then you know the
gulag guy says you go arrest him and
then some low-level dude some low-level
dude goes he's a criminal you know I
don't know is that is that is that a
good guy no he's taking someone and
putting him in in what we call the gulag
yeah or the cultural or the cultural
revolution in in China where literally
there was walks of Shame against
capitalists against individuals who had
private property because those were the
ones that were responsible for
everyone's pain and suffering and they
literally humiliated them tortured them
in public squares with people cheering
it on dude like what they're doing those
are order followers those are back the
blue people that should be questioned
that's what the exact same thing they're
doing to the j6 prisoners yep it's the
same thing you got to go and bend the
knee and say that you don't like Trump
you don't like uh you know you don't
believe in what he was saying and you
know humiliation but I mean we just had
MLK Day right yeah uh under Trump they
released the letter from the FBI telling
MLK to commit suicide I mean it didn't
didn't I mean this is what people have
been saying that the fbis wouldn't have
killed them I mean yeah no we don't have
like there's a civil court there was a
civil case in 1999 where a jury found
the U.S government complicit in the
assassination of MLK and the MLK family
won that particular lawsuit yes I'm
gonna take their word for it and so and
so you know we have all this history
think of uh JFK and RFK they spied on
MLK under the FBI the doj Attorney
General was RFK he signed off on it they
have a picture of a signature the
president was JFK these are the greatest
civil rights leaders of our time and
they're the ones that spied on and told
him to kill himself and then you know
what they did Herbert Hoover was the
director of the FBI they named the FBI
building after him
I just want to add to this go ahead
Jackson on the 20 Bill exactly just
hated the central banks yeah and and
then
that they make people worship the cross
when that's the thing they killed him
with but but the the Hoover thing is
important here because a lot of people
are saying it was actually Hoover who
was responsible for this who had a lot
of skeletons in his closet and was
allegedly also a cross-dresser but the
FBI did so many Sinister things
especially under cointel probe a lot of
people don't even uh know this but they
had full on disinformation
um organizations and psyops running so
people wouldn't organize together and
what they did to the MLK was it just
spying on him wasn't just writing
letters saying hey kill yourself they
they they were watching his every move
they knew that he cheated on his wife
took that information and when MLK was
in jail they went to his wife and said
here's the evidence here's the tapes of
MLK talking to his mistress divorce him
that is just absolute evil their number
one tactic in a movement is to go in and
divide it thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time